welcome back to las vegas now cake boss
buddy v has officially opened his fifth
restaurant here in las vegas the boss
cafe and things just got a little
cheesier joining us is buddy's
father-in-law let's see if i can do it
moro belgium
and
yes perfect that was good for you all
right we're talking all about the motts
i'm sorry i'm sorry no no no no no no we
don't serve matzo oh okay we serve the
muts turn around for a second i want to
show everybody
turn around for a second let me show you
this is the show it's all about the
books
i need one of those shirts i gotta fit
into the family here you guys this all
looks amazing i we gotta jump right to
it what is happening over here
right so this is the mutts
okay so this is like the star and the
whole foundation of what boss cafe is
okay it's a tip of the hat to i'm from
new york but he's from jersey we're part
of from the same part of culture in the
world and over there it's normal to have
fresh mozzarella made in these delis and
these cafes that are on a daily basis
and we wanted to bring a little bit of
that to las vegas wow so this is being
made daily a few times a day throughout
and we're making sandwiches as you see
here we make pizzas with it and it's all
about the muts here we also have the
iconic carlos bakery we're featuring all
of the the greatest hits over at carl's
bakery which are featured at boscafen on
a daily basis oh i'm always drawn to
that rainbow cake it's so delicious and
you said a sandwich but i mean that is
not your typical sandwich
sandwich i'm learning so much today
those look amazing and let's come back
to the mutts over here for a second when
you order it how does it come out or
what's the process like so exactly what
you see here he's forming it and we're
going to drop it right into here you're
going to get it like first-hand
experience i'm standing next to it yes
and the the kitchen is completely open
so you'll be able to see all the mutz
masters and maro's like the he's like
the jedi of what's making i love it he
is we call him mutz that's actually his
nickname at the place
i'm going to give you a first-hand taste
at what it is like to have it okay
straight
from the bowl oh my gosh this just does
not even look real to me it's too you
see this kind of sweating already yeah
and i'm going to put you just a little
bit of basil pesto on here wow and
that's all you really need so start with
good ingredients
exactly this is and it's all about the
artwork here so go for it i'm going in
for it and as i take a bite tell me
about some of the pizzas and other
things that you got on there so we have
a few different pizzas it's actually
something we call bakery pizza
it's kind of like a cross between like a
grandma style pizza and a focaccia style
it's something that buddy's father
you know made in the bakeries when he
was growing up so we brought that so no
one else is really doing it like we are
it's sauce heavy and we're using just
great fresh ingredients obviously the
cheese and the different types of
pepperoni and the sausage that we're
using it's all top of the line
ingredients i really wish i could say i
heard what you just said but i'm really
distracted by what i just said i
understand it happens it happens the
roast beef is one of our signature
sandwiches we we marinate it overnight
we roast it in house we slice it nice
and thin of course with the fresh cheese
and you get a choice between roasted
sweet peppers or the hot peppers uh you
know so you have the ability to do it
the way that you like it and you know we
have classics like the soprano and the
turkey plt that we do with a slimy style
pancetta i am drooling over here this is
so amazing you guys have brought a true
authentic italian new jersey you know
taste to our city and we're so happy to
have all of you guys part of our
community and we know how important
family is to buddy and to all of you
what do you want people to feel when
they come into any of the restaurants
but especially boss cafes you feel the
love yeah of course you know what i mean
and that's what it is we're all fun
everyone's like you know who they are
when you come in and everybody likes to
talk and it's all you know we're all
having a good time and that's what it
should be when you come in it's an
experience it's a lot it's a lot of fun
you feel the love and you leave and
family you know that
is buddy's father-in-law oh it is a
family affair
it is definitely been
i had to give my daughter away to him
he's a good man he's a very good person
now he's showing off with his braid here
now i'm showing off on my braids oh my
gosh it's so beautiful i'm going to have
to keep cutting away at this this is
delicious thank you guys so much and
really quickly if people want to come
visit you at the boss cafe where are you
located we are located at the link oh
all right i'll be at the link seven days
a week but for now i'll be here eating a
lot of this what's the most
all right thank you guys so much for
being here rocky i'll send it over to
you thank